so that this 49ers team reeling already
coming into the game richard sherman
star cornerback on injured reserve
george kittle not available
because of a knee sprain he suffered on
the hospital ball that jimmy g threw
last week right this is a teenage boy
ravaged by injuries
throughout yeah d ford was out yesterday
and and uh they're
just a couple hours down the road from
here in west virginia until next week
when they go back
to metlife stadium to play the giants
and that's
the concern now because in the aftermath
of the game what are we hearing
yeah all of the complaints about the
turf at metlife stadium
and the lower leg injuries resulting
from feet getting caught and it's spongy
and
the league's going to look into it look
at half certifies every field before
every game
but but they're going to look into it
because the 49ers and the giants play
there next week then giants and jets
play there
every week i mean there's a game there
every week all season long
mike first off and and again you know
as a football player you get trained to
look at things
and and i swear to you last week during
the monday night football game against
the new york giants and the pittsburgh
steelers just to address the turf
i noticed it then james connor heard his
foot and ankle last week when he had to
come out of the game he caught a ball
in the left flat his foot got caught in
the turf i noticed it big ben
think about him got hit early remember
he limped around
foot got caught in the turf they lost
their right tackler i'm blanking on his
name uh
uh banner yeah exactly lose him
similar type of turf type thing there so
i have noticed it and of course you know
not sitting here trying to say i notice
everything but either way it's something
i look for
and you see i saw it again yesterday
it's troubling yeah they got to figure
that out
that's not good players wouldn't
complain about that right
unless they really felt like this
doesn't feel right
they're not wired that way and i bet
that i mean
guaranteed it's just something they felt
right away when they went on the field
like man this is tight there's no
give you know your feet can't move once
you plant them in the ground
and that's scary and it happened a
number of times yesterday in the game
other side of the coin i talked to
jordan reed the 49ers tight end had a
couple of touchdown
catches yesterday and i asked him about
it as part of the conversation and and
he kind of sheepishly said i didn't
really notice anything
and uh the giants and steelers
i've learned they had even though the
steelers had those injuries they didn't
come with concerns no complaints about
the quality of the turf and uh from from
the jets perspective
uh the the information i got was we were
too busy getting our faces kicked in to
notice
the turf which uh given the final score
31 to 13 that would make some sense
what does this mean for the 49ers though
moving forward to not have these guys
well
it's i i mean holy cow i mean first off
raheem mozart we've seen what he can do
you know early in the game the last two
weeks he's a home run hitter
so not to have him then you know no nick
bosa
nick bosa as we heard from anybody at
the super bowl last year as we saw with
our own two eyes
he's already regarded as one of the best
defensive players in football
and we know this is a defense that
doesn't have a great secondary
and is built around the pass rush so
when you have nick bosa out
as your best pass rusher on your team d
ford who is
always hurt in battling injuries his
whole career
i'm not trying to be a jerk or anything
like that and now you got jimmy
garoppolo on one leg
george kittle's not in there they're
starting center weston richberg's not
there
demo samuel their best receiver is not
there
so yeah they're very fortunate that
right now with the state of their
football team
they're playing the jets and now the
giants two teams that even though
they're banged up
they're still better than and hopefully
they can kind of withstand this stretch
but
it's already starting to get to the
point where it's starting to make me
think about like whoa
wait can they sustain this how big of a
player are they going to be in the nfc
this year
because you're getting down here now to
like another injury or two and you're
gonna go oh
this isn't the same football team
they're in deep trouble and you don't
know where it goes from here but they
got a very favorable early schedule as
you can see here on tv
giants eagles dolphins gives them a few
weeks to at least get healthy
before they start a brutal stretch there
uh with the patriots and rams in week
six
bose is the killer that's the one pillar
because
bosa is the guy who changed that team
last year he transformed that defense
he helped that pass rush reach the next
level so you don't have to worry about
the back end because the quarterback is
too worried about being thrown on his
back end and
now without bosa you lose that and
that's what's going to be the killer for
the 49ers
regardless of the depth they have
elsewhere and they you know they flirted
with some guys didn't they have ziggy
onsen
yeah he's probably going to be back
sooner rather than later they got to
find somebody to come in and rush the
pass their second most important
position in football other than
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports